the g20 summit is underway in rome as
leaders from the world's major
industrialized nations meet
outgoing german chancellor angela merkel
is among the dignitaries who are in the
italian capital for the two-day
gathering
among the topics being discussed is the
coronavirus with emergency workers
invited to join leaders for a photo
tackling global warming is also top of
the agenda ahead of the cop 26 climate
conference which begins on sunday
most of those attending the g20 in rome
will travel onward to glasgow for that
key u.n climate summit
they are the two most prominent roman
catholics on the world stage pope
francis and u.s president joe biden the
devout catholic keeps a photograph of
the pontiff on his desk at the white
house on friday he met with his hero
face to face at the vatican
and
you are the most significant warrior for
peace i've ever met
for more than an hour the two leaders
spoke privately about climate change the
pandemic and poverty the visit is the
prequel of two major summits happening
this weekend
in rome the g20 and in glasgow the cop
26 climate summit back home biden
suffered a setback for his pricey
infrastructure plan that focuses in part
on the environment
but ahead of the g20 these young people
are pushing for action on the climate
we are thinking about the future of our
planet but not in our interests not in
the research of the young people and we
are going to scream in our streets that
we want a different world in terms of
climate in terms of health
getting more jabs in people's arms in
rich and poor countries is also a
priority for the first face-to-face
summit since the pandemic hit but before
biden joins in on the global cooperation
to tackle monumental problems he first
had a very public mia culpa with french
president emmanuel macron biden
apologized for the us's botched handling
of a submarine deal with australia that
cut france out what happened
was to use
english phrase what we did was clumsy
it was not done with a lot of grace
i was under the impression of certain
things that happened that hadn't
happened
and but
i want to make it clear
france is an extreme
extremely valuable
for his part macron is ready to move
forward
i believe that this was after our two
exchanges in september and october an
important meeting because following the
acas affair
we have initiated real common work and a
political response and reinforce
cooperation between the united states of
america and france
both sides hope the rebuilding of trust
will help bring about the change these
young people are marching for
and for more on this let's talk to dw
correspondent alexandra von naman who's
at the g20 summit in rome alexandra it's
going to last two days what's on the
agenda today
the leaders today are going to talk
about the coronavirus pandemic and they
will talk about ways to accelerate
vaccine production and their
distribution they are expected to back
the goal of vaccinated vaccinating 70
percent of the world population by mid
2022 however we have to say that as for
now only barely 50
of the world population have received
one jab so this is a very difficult
topic another topic that they will be
talking about is the global economy and
we expect some leaders to raise the
issue of soaring energy prices and
disruptions to global supply chains and
the leaders are also expected to endorse
a minimum corporate tax rate of 15
and that is going as they hope to lead
to billions or in additional revenues
and that that is that decision is
already being described as a once in a
generation achievement
and alexander when it comes to the
environment the u.n secretary general
antonio guterres demanded a signal from
the g20 leaders ahead of the u.n climate
summit in glasgow where they're heading
afterwards uh is that likely to happen
well we have to say that there is
actually no reason to be optimistic that
the g20 leaders will really pave the way
to the un conference in glasgow by
showing that there are committed to more
ambitious climate goals they are still
negotiating whether in the end the g20
will agree
to be
carbon neutral by 2050 and we are
already hearing from some countries for
example from china that they are saying
well we are rejecting calls for more
ambitious goals and when we take when we
look at the u.s for example joe biden's
climate plan is still still in congress
so at the moment unfortunately we have
to say that there is no reason to be
very optimistic
okay and there are a lot of
the main g20 leaders but xi jinping the
leader of china the world's biggest co2
producer is not attending in person just
over video link it's the same situation
for russia's president vladimir putin
does that all make it harder to get a
deal
yes of course because china and russia
are so important players when it comes
to their climate crisis but also when it
comes to other topics such as for
example the soaring energy prices it
would be good for all g20 leaders to sit
together and have a face-to-face
conference
conversation that confrontation sorry
but this is not going to happen and it's
really we have to lower our expectations
because those two leaders putin and she
are not attending the summit in person
yeah a bit of a freudian slip and i
think we can well understand why uh
alexander fondament thanks so much for
that